now what's it like joining the
juggernaut that is bond I would think
pretty extraordinary
yes fantastically exciting really really
exciting em we're having a great old
time and it's lovely that what I'm so
pleased about is that the film is so so
good because I would've had to do this
even if I was terrible it's pretty lucky
the libraries because of commute it can
be difficult that when you're like this
no but the film is really extraordinary
and the critics have just gone nuts fur
which is brilliant but I think it's for
the audience and I think they really are
I watched it yesterday I was totally
blown away by it because the one of the
pleasures of being in a kind of an
ensemble cast like there's big sections
of it that you're not in because they go
to different storylines at different
time I was really blown away by some of
the set pieces and some of the
performances because bonds is something
so extraordinary for all of us I think
that it's a it's an event it's a film
it's like we take it around the world
and we show off about it it's like an
export Ian's bomb like nothing else
it's really weird cuz I mean it is a spy
you goes around the world sleeping with
women and killing people
yeah it's just it's part of the culture
isn't it now and I think that's Sam you
know it's nice to have film tradition I
think that's really really important
because it's hard to build that up you
know
yeah very difficult and it's very it's
very important that it's kept relevant
and so I really like the idea that some
of the storylines that I'm involved in
in the film is about surveillance and
technology and how we use technique that
technology for for either good or for
for bad and and what we do to hold on to
our privacy I think is so pertinent and
I think it's it should be applauded that
it's that the guys have included that in
the story so do you think we are
monitored too much I do I do think we
are like my own personal views that I
think we are I think it's so it's scary
I think it's very important that things
are we are at least given the option to
opt out if we want I think people don't
don't read the terms and conditions of
things because who would read a 16-page
treaty and terms and conditions for
joining a having a mobile phone or
whatever you know it's it's we're
fighting a losing battle so I think it's
it's to be held on to and the other
thing you mentioned there was the fact
that bond stays relevant and that's
probably I would think one of the
reasons it's continued for so long as it
keeps reinventing I mean in the future
do you can you see bond going even
further could he be a she could he be a
black actor yeah I think it's very
important to us you don't play black and
you don't play female that's what a
female bond doesn't you can't act being
a woman you can't act being black you
can't act being gay so whatever
attributes the the person the human
being or the character that's written
that brings to the to the role that's
what we should be focusing on and
whether that's a woman or a man or a
straight man or a gay woman or whatever
the hell the combination we want it to
be we should look beyond the label and
look at the attributes that Ian Fleming
is looking for and if they if that human
being has those attributes and then
they're suitable for them but there's
also the argument that bond is such a
such an important film franchising yes
such a standing globally that it could
do something really brave I don't know
things in mind I think that's absolutely
the reason why but it's important to
hold on to that you could have any
number of any combination of those those
things you could have those and I think
it's important to be brave yeah
absolutely but but but not for for no
reason I think has to be very considered
choice might be a bit much having all of
them in together might say those those
things those things aren't attributes
they're just they're just facts you know
what I mean so you know what what Daniel
brings is completely different too
Roger Moore brings or what Sean Connery
brings and I don't that's the easy code
that they're you know straight male male
and male actor but you don't talk about
that you talk about their attributes you
talk about whether they're dangerous
whether they're suave or or all that
stuff and so I think a woman could be
suave or dangerous
or she could be not so ever dangerous or
so it's nothing to do with the label of
what a woman loves because it's a woman
or a black person or a gay person or
whatever and I think it's it's important
to look at the attributes of the human
being more than anything else